December 18th 2015 the quarantine zone
in the middle of Manhattan later known
as the dark zone was abandoned by the
government in the Joint Task Force they
left behind weapons equipment thousands
of civilians and the first wave of
division agents although it has assumed
that the majority of the first wave were
killed the went rogue there are a number
that just simply disappeared what we do
know is that some of them managed to
escape the quarantine zone and make
their way to the outside of Manhattan
Island in this series we're going to
follow these agents and speculate on
what happened to them based on the
psychological profiles and the location
of where their watches and other
information was found
[Music]
you
Raymond or Ravitz had a tough start to
life when he was orphaned at the age of
17 after his mother died of breast
cancer
this resulted in him dropping out of
school shortly after regs of its classic
OCD symptoms and is easily bored if not
challenged here's an IQ of 186 and has
achieved nearly jandira status in the
white hat hacking community ray is
capable of juggling the massive amounts
of data on his head he isn't swayed by
money or any other kind of bribe what
drives ray more than anything is having
a task worthy of the skills by the age
of 21 he had hacked into two
multinationals but was never prosecuted
due to lack of evidence all proceeds
were donated to charity ray is a noted
expert on Internet privacy and works as
a cyber security consultant he holds
deeply anti-authoritarian views and
delights and shutting government
backdoors into consumer information
Ray's watch an ID was found in the
garment district in an alleyway
suspicious of the government and always
ready to stick it to the man Ray was an
interesting choice for the strategic
homeland division this personality would
be the perfect candidate for Aaron kinas
cause
Ray's beliefs and freedom and
hostilities towards Authority would have
been the prime target for kena given how
the events unfolded in the dark zone the
distrust of the government was already
there but it's hard to tell whether kena
was ever in contact with ray based on
the locations watch was found it's
possible that they never met ray was
unfortunate with the route that he chose
to take while he was moving away from
the dark zone he stumbled across an area
completely overrun with cleaners in fact
he was in the direct path of one of the
cleanest patrols led by one of the
lieutenant's and his last moments were
likely at the business end of a cleaners
rifle though it's still possible that he
made it through this area and kept
moving towards key locations specified
by kena as his high level of IT security
experience would have been an integral
asset for kinas cause
from a young age angela was a high
achiever she holds a PhD in mechanical
engineering from Stanford and is an
expert in robotics a pioneer in the use
of robotics for people with special
needs she is also a mechanical prodigy
who can build and or fix anything
Angela tends to be quiet but holds
strong opinions and is not easily swayed
her father was a former Olympic boxer
and trained her from the age of seven
she continues to train and recently
achieved a black belt in Brazilian
jiu-jitsu angela is driven energetic and
self-sufficient she works well alone but
can also function well while leading a
team a compulsive problem solver she
does not suffer fools gladly it has been
noted on a record that she is
particularly harsh on those that don't
pull their weight
however she respects Authority as long
she feels authority has been earned
Angela's watch an ID was found
underground in the Clinton district
above this location there was a large
number of writer gangs in the area but
underground it was safe and easily
defendable on her way away from the dark
zone it appears as though Angela headed
straight towards the New York Police
Department only a block away unlikely to
be swayed by keno she was probably
trying to put some space between her and
the rogue agents and the police
department would have seemed like a good
place to get some backup from the local
JTF unfortunately straight away she
would have noticed that the police
station had already been gutted from the
inside out the LMB had torn the place
apart and there was evidence that the
prisoners being held there were executed
in a brutal fashion no one survived
Angela escaped and found safety closeby
in an underground network of tunnels
after gathering her bearings as likely
that she realized that she was on her
own now on one side though a rogue
agents ready to take her out if she
doesn't join and on the other side there
is the JTF and government they could all
really be working under the assumption
that all first wave agents have turned
rogue at this point angela removed her
watch and any way that she could be
tracked it's hard to tell where she went
after this she either headed north past
Central Park to hide out until the
situation sorts itself out or maybe she
continued with her mission and has gone
south to follow some possible leads
level-headed and cool in a crisis
Tanisha's superb at complex
problem-solving she inspires fierce
loyalty and co-workers if not the
occasional jealousy after studying a way
traffic control at Fort Rucker she then
served at Al Udeid in Ashgabat and
received the highest ratings at every
posting reports talk about a situation
where Tanisha safely landed all planes
when the tower went dead at ashgabat she
has now worked at all three major
airports in the New York metropolitan
area she says that she finds the work
soothing compared to her time overseas
but is publicly commented about
potentially returning to service Tanisha
lacks empathy and cannot understand why
not all of her peers can reach your high
level of performance this isn't to say
that she's arrogant she just genuinely
doesn't understand
Tanisha's ID and watch can be found in
the Flatiron District in an underground
car park she had put quite some distance
between herself and the dark zone and it
almost left the area completely in her
last known location there were no
hostiles anywhere near her
but for any number of reasons much like
a lot of the other agents that escaped
the dark zone she decided to remove her
watch an ID and leave the area of all of
the agents that we've looked at so far
there is very little to go on from here
she just vanished there are a series of
ropes that followed the path she was
taking that lead directly into a large
group of wreckers including one of the
Rocky lieutenants she could have got
mixed up with them but other than that
this area is relatively peaceful and
abundant with supplies it's possible
that she's long gone from the area but
at the same time she could still be
hanging around watching over these
streets
Regan Murphy comes from a law
enforcement family her father
grandfather and three siblings all work
for police departments understandably
her family was very supportive of a
decision to follow her father into
Worcester Police Department
Regan has been wounded twice in the line
of duty
both times preventing harm from coming
to civilians she was decorated for both
incidents Regan was recruited into the
US Marshal Service after three years on
the force and has served with
distinction on occasion she seems eager
to throw herself into harm's way
who willingness to sacrifice for the job
is admirable but on occasion takes it
too far she has been written up once for
lack of attention to self care and her
superiors have spoken of difficulty
finding marshals to partner with her due
to a tendency to take risks
Regan's watch an ID can be found just
outside of the dark zone in the Kips Bay
district loyal and not one to run from a
challenge
she has simply fallen back to regroup
it's likely that she was pursued by a
large number of Records that forced her
to take cover at the top of a nearby
building as a former police officer and
a current agent of the government the
Rikers would have taken particular
liking to her if she'll successful in
pushing back the Rikers it's very likely
that she stormed straight back into the
quarantine zone from here she luckily
came face to face with Erin keener and
we know what the outcome of this would
have been however this would have been
the best case scenario for Regan the
other possible outcome was that she was
overrun by the Rikers and captured and
then taken to the nearby strike a
stronghold at Lexington Event Center
where her last moments would have been
less than Pleasant but the strange thing
in all of this is that her ID was found
in pretty much pristine condition and it
doesn't look like there's any sort of
struggle at all removing a Rochon ID
doesn't really fit in with her profile
Regan was never going to run and hide
from the situation regardless of how
dangerous it was so why did she leave it
behind
these are just my theories and
speculations based off the story
missions encounters Intel and
psychological profiles of the agents
it's completely possible that they
simply died after contracting the virus
or were killed by one of the many
hostile factions there are many many
different possible outcomes but tell me
what do you think happened to these
agents in the next lost agents video
we'll be covering so and you may know a
little bit about this is about the time
I like to thank my patrons for
supporting the channel you guys have
been amazing and a while back when I was
put in a position of choosing whether to
continue with YouTube or to take on a
second job it was you that kept me here
doing what I love but I've decided to
close down my patreon page because I
really feel like I'm not able to provide
the value that patrons paying me on a
monthly basis deserve I simply do not
have the time right now while also
keeping videos coming out on a regular
basis people can still provide one-off
donations if they'd like to but if I was
going to open up a patreon page again
I'd be making sure that I'm in a
position to further enhance the
experience of those wanting to
participate thanks again and I'll leave
you now with an image of my son dressing
up for Halloween as probably the least
scary Deadpool that you've ever seen
Cheers
[Music]
you
[Music]
you